well this is gonna be the last david
pakman show episode for a while we're
not going away altogether in fact we're
actually in the middle of a pretty cool
expansion and I'll have more to tell you
about that when we get back but we are
going to be on a planned break and part
of what we're doing is growing our
financial support we're trying to bring
in 500 new financial supporters so that
in the future during these breaks we
would actually have rotating staff and
we would be able to continue producing
new shows during the break we are not
there yet so just a reminder if we reach
those 500 new supporters either through
membership patreon or YouTube
sponsorship instead of telling you that
we are going to be going away for a
little while on break next week we would
just be rotating staff and continuing to
produce new shows during the vacation so
something to think about big
announcements will be happening upon our
return we've got a lot of very very
interesting things in the works there
will be new programming on YouTube
throughout the break there are a number
of different stories segments extra
audience phone calls and things that we
have recorded which we'll be publishing
during our vacation there will be on the
public podcast feed repeat classic
episodes and I want to just remind
everybody that the show isn't ending I
know every time we take a break I will
get invariably a couple dozen emails
from people saying did the show end is
there is there no more David Pakman show
have you called it quits and no we're
not calling it quits and either the
truth is if we were calling it quits you
know me I build everything up for weeks
or months if I'm at all able to I would
definitely be building up the end of the
David Pakman show for more than just
waiting until the last show and
mentioning it casually or not mentioning
it at all so the David Pakman show is
not ending we are actually planning to
grow we've got three to five new
platforms that we've been invited to
publish our content on more about that
when we come back we are looking to add
staffing we are looking to improve the
program technologically so a lot of
really really great things going on
and we will return my concern always is
will major news break during our
vacation and if so the question is will
I live stream and the answer is probably
if I have good service a good internet
service I will talk to you on today's
bonus show and Pat will talk to you on
today's bonus show about our vacation
plans very very good program for you
today we've got a great interview we
will answer audience questions we will
take live calls remember 500 new
supporters is the target to prevent
these vacations where we go off the air
patreon membership and YouTube
sponsorship